it really isn't that thick but there was
enough ice on babes Mill Lake to draw
children out onto it
four were rescued but they spent the day
here checking to see if there were
others
of the four boys that were pulled out
three died later in hospital
one of the boys is a close friend of
Tommy those all played an awesome then
one got one other legs got stuck in the
eyes and two of his friends went to go
save him but they're all Fallen
Katie was at the lake just before it
happened on Sunday afternoon
they were just down where the entrance
of the water is on the solid here just
playing that's all I saw Christmas is
about children that's why we do it and
to know that there's going to be
children up there
it's just because of bab's meal like
it's weird it's a weird feeling
yesterday's incident is a stark reminder
to us all of the dangers of Open Water
especially during the winter months
another boy H6 is still in the critical
condition in hospital one of my officers
was trying to punch through the ice to
to actually rescue the the children
themselves can you just give us some
information regarding the ongoing work
here at the lake and whether or not
there are further people unaccounted for
we have to be 100 certain that there is
no one else possibly in the water at
this time
we it's important to stress though that
we've had no contact from anybody
suggesting that there's anybody else
missing
we don't yet know whether the boys here
were being supervised or not but once
the ice had started to crack it all
happened very quickly there is perhaps
no Starker example of just how dangerous
a frozen lake or Pond can be
families here applauded as one of the
fire Crews paid their own tribute
all of the Emergency Services here want
the story from this Lake to be a very
clear warning to others
searching on the water has now stopped
so they gathered in their hundreds to
reflect and to remember
they prayed too for the youngest victim
who still lies critical in a hospital
bed
well told me is that they've seen for us
this evening families grieving to arm a
community and mourning A desperate
tragedy for everyone there
yes it was a very quiet very moving
vigil here at the side of the lake this
evening and really the boys were all
from this part of the West Midlands and
one of them who has been named locally
this evening as ten-year-old Jack
Johnson who's described to us today as a
boy who died a hero because he went into
the lake to try to save others this is a
tragedy that is spread here between two
primary schools and one of them
Anthony's just down the road from here
said this evening never has our motto
been more meaningful actions speak
louder than words we will support our
children and families the best that we
can there is no criminal investigation
here it is simply an awful instance that
should never have happened but the fact
that it has or perhaps make others think
twice as we now have these expanses of
ice up and down the United Kingdom in
these Sub-Zero temperatures they are not
playgrounds however enticing they may
seem